alors on joue contre 2 a pas écoutés on
peut en avoir un peu ce qui fait il joue
pas mal on va jouer tranquille en termes
témoin je vais regarder le chat en même
temps et je pense qu'il aura combien
moi je vois bien une victoire de carl
scène d'un point d'écart je vois bien
une victoire de carl c avec un point
d'écart sa bien aimée only on a bien
aimé l'addition sur l'écart dans la
dernière vidéo sera bien plus web on
écoute et on va re ok pour le moment
peut-être dû faire cavalier 5
je vais peut-être jouer camaïeu
s'inquiète plus fort comme j'essaye plus
de lire le chat que de me concentrer
on va essayer de vie c'est cette case
bonjour un peu de manière originale car
la scène et côté à combien sur les sites
de paris j'ai vu à 1,40 par le
fonctionnement des cadences ben oui en
fait tu as du temps qui s'ajoute à après
un certain nombre de coups joués
alors cette position là qu'est ce que ça
vaut bien envie de faire un petit coup
de dames 2 allait attaquer là bas et
peut-être planter ses quatre québécois
1h40
bref belge explique ray ça demain pas le
toc
ils ont une heure quarante puis après
ils ont 50 minutes de rajouts après 60e
et 15 minutes chaos avec 30 secondes de
toute la partie à 1,40 tu veux dire
t'y connais rien en côte je croyais que
tu parlais d'une heure quarante va en
fait oui je suis mise 1 euros tu vas
gagner si gagnes ou tu vas tu vas faire
un bénéfice de 40 centimes si tu mets
sens tu vas récupérer tamise de sang et
or à 40 euros de gains nets et caruana
gelé vue à 2,80 serre que si tu mets
sens tu vas avoir 280 euros tu vas
récupérer tamise 200 il faut un bénéfice
de 180 mais je pense personnellement si
les gens qui jouent sur les sites
internationaux je parierais sur le
handicap
caruana plus 1,5 donc c'est à dire que
tu gagnes le match gagne s'y perd 6,5
5.5 à 5,50 à 1,50
donc c'est moins risqué
je sais pas ce qui se passe sur table
français si ce fut curieux et j'ai pas
envie de calculer
du coup c'est simple
voilà de 80 il a un peu loin la tour en
c1 d'affaires fou bessin contre adam
français 7 on repartira par la salut à
60k tarder ça bonsoir à toi bon là il
menace poule b saint qui avons un peu
joué avec le feu ouais non ça c'est un
peu con quand même je vais faire à
quatre pour jouer avec le feu et s'il
garde et madame hamm et j'ai peut-être
me la faire enfermer
d'un autre côté on a tous envie de me
voir me faire enfermer la dame du coup
j'hésite
ça me ferait très plaisir que je me
fasse en fermer la valve et on va
essayer c'est risqué parce que je peux
j'aurais pu faire damas quatre dames d1
et revenir mais là je venais en danger
parce que madame elle et elle peut se
faire enfermer
envie de tenter un truc drôle alors à 5
fu ici j'ai envie de faire dame 17 et
surtour des huit dames français cette
année c'est dangereux on fait c'est
hyper dangereux
du coup c'est marrant mais fou paceman
dame 17 c'est marrant on tient sur le
fil pourrait nous ce qu'on veut faire
maintenant c'est clairement a6 a7 a8 un
steak s'y trouve rien
le pion fil sur cavaliers b8 du coup on
à damas quatre leur tour voire même dame
a vite pour ce faire plaisent même si
damas huit grands moyens mais bon on
pourra essayer
et sinon menace a6 a7 a8 tout ça on
avait vu maintenant fougue de alors
e-menaces fou prend les tours prend des
deux donc on va faire qu'un petit coup
de cavalier e 5 avec l'idée surtout
reprend des deux de faire 20 km prend 17
alors ça j'avais vu alors est-ce qu'on
fait le joli cavaliers c6 ou est-ce
qu'on fait le pragmatique d'anne decis
donc elle sait si c'est dangereux comme
gay peut se retrouver enfermés ou alors
on fait le maran qui prend 17 tours
prend ses 7 qui est prend v8 et on
essaie de
c'est un peu concret mais bon
non ça nous permet à faire d'anne decis
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est pourquoi
j'ai pas le son quand je joue alors sur
qui les pronostics faits d'armes prend
1,5 et je me retrouve avec une
superposition du coup parce que eh ben
je reste avec mes deux pions plus qui
sont passés
ouais normalement pas le temps qu'on
pourra changer de langue mais une
nouvelle fois je décide ainsi ça fait
une semaine je réussis pas avoir une
seule réponse sur le texte sur la
technique pas le toc alors je vais faire
à 6 il fait mettre le foin à 5 et je
vais le passer en b 6
ouais non non je pense en fait y aura de
toute façon accès aux trucs en anglais
donc ça c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle
normalement thorax est apte à tous à
tous avec le package français anglais et
aura accès à tous donc ça ce sera quand
même cool bon là on est on est très bien
maintenant on va pouvoir mettre le pion
à 7 du coup on aura un jour de une
chaîne de folie
de la peinture donc oui en revanche la
bonne nouvelle c'est que de toute façon
les caméras vous les aurez c'est sûr à
100% et les commentaires en anglais je
suis sûr à 99 %
c'est que vu que les parties durent
longtemps je vais pas m'ennuyer un peu
si sûrement 1
et comme ici c'est pas moi qui
organisais qu'est ce que je peux y faire
je viens là bas mais peut-être un piège
tourbe et un tour prend à 7
allez je veux voir si le voir tomber un
tour prend 1,7 à il l'a vu mais dan les
huit échecs
pas de chance donc si je prenais une
tour où la dame
ça faisait échec et mat du couloir mais
là je peux prendre sur l'échec et
reprendre sur échec cela petites
tactiques qui fait mal 2 ap en sueur 2
ap en sueur de l'ap hm méga sûr j'ai un
bug bizarre donc sympa la petite
tactique on va revenir dessus parce
qu'elle était jolie alors tour c b1 donc
j'attaque la dame et je menace tour des
huit là dessus est prévu tout reprend à
7 assez élégant idée je prends des six
points et si je prends à sète il prend
v1 et la dame b 8 échecs intermédiaire
menace dame prend des six nettement donc
prisa et la dame forcé et tout reprendre
et 8 il n'a pas le temps de prendre pour
un sur un parce que c'est sûr échec
donc assez sympa comme tactique voilà
c'était sympa on joue contre eux poisson
jaune viellot fiche alors il vous fait
ses cadres etc sera conduit avec nokia
c6
on va faire des 50 seuil est de jouer
une figurine shiko shiko shiko in
african très attention je commence à
chanter je connais pas du tout on va
garder notre fou donc ouais c'est
surtout le premier jour un qui va je
m'inquiète que pour demain après demain
sinon les mecs voilà enfin je me répète
je me répète un petit par rapport à ce
que je disais mais je ne m'inquiète pas
du tout pour pour le stream de lundi par
exemple lundi je sais que ce sera bon je
m'inquiète aucunement pour le stream de
lundi il y aura pas de souci ça va aller
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
non y'a que pour celui de demain et
samedi que je m'inquiète le reste après
je sais que s'ils ont des soucis et
régleront ce serait pas la première fois
d'ailleurs il avait eu un souci pour
chez plus quel tournoi où là alors là
une petite tactique a les mêmes chercher
dans le tchat
ça va bien se passer allez on cherche la
tactique km et 4 merci charpentier un
classique 1 du coup alors ça peut-être
pas forcément l'habitude sur les
ouvertures à d4 d5 ça arrive pas tout le
temps bien sûr il ya les simples c'est
la reine il faut l'avoir pas forcément
simple pour tout le monde il faut la
voir
alors je sais pas pourquoi le ce on s'en
va je vais faire un refresh les
problèmes de soins et chaises comme donc
là on va prendre du cavalier ou du fou
non j'aime bien prendre du cavalier ça
me permet de simplifier la position
technique favel c'est toi qui évoqué
vinoir la classe la chance
voilà juste prendre et on va faire des
6es et c5
il y avait un truc et histoires et
situations quand j'entends le même
problème j'en peux plus des bugs j'en
peux plus les mecs débat que j'en ai
marre projet pris le fuite et simo verra
parce que j'ai une pièce de plus mais
qui avait quatre c'est sûrement plus
fort mais jugé une pièce de plus donc je
m'en fous mais beckham devait être plus
fort est de ggp a vu juste mais je sens
qu'ils les soucis de soins
pareil à des soucis de son nez oui je
joue assez misérablement
ça arrive
alors il prend ici on apprend j'apprends
dans des 500 il obliger un même la
position va simplifier tu vas rester
avec une pièce de plus on va faire tour
des huit va continuer changer
normalement cette facile à gagner tu
vois c'est pour ça que j'ai que j'ai
pris en c1 ce que mon avantage matériel
est bien trop important bon après je
peux me planter je suis pas méga
concentré on a quand même idée de faire
tout reprend des cinq sur dame prend
prendra en b2c reprendre la tour on
remettra une tour en des 8 tu vois et
plus on échange de pièces plus notre fou
va se voir
donc voilà il échange en plus de lui
même mais au cas où on pourra toujours
revenir en effet de départ le chat s'il
n'y aura pas de père pète on va pouvoir
s'en prendre à son roi commence assez
basique à gagner mais en blitz il faut
toujours faire attention
voilà donc voilà on continue la même
logique en fait j'essaie de lui et
changer les pièces
je ne peux pas faire jordan détroit
équidés d'un prend des deux dames des 8
es tu as et chaque échec parce que le
truc c'est qu'en fait il n'a pas une
diagonale de perpète à cause du fou qui
reviendrait fuite ben tu vois je suis
pépère le chat thual apparemment même
chose damas trois tu as le fouillis
serre je protège mon pions il vient là
et là je mets laurent rachou non je fais
ffp par le ch a fait fi de pépère le
shass blindes leroy et va devoir faire
dame c4 et j'ai fait raciste b5 bekkat à
5 à 4 à 3 à regarder car il ne peut rien
attaqué il en sûr il va se prendre des 5
à 5 va avoir des 5 paraît juste faire
gaffe de passe pour un truc à un moment
donné
[Musique]
bon alors à la rigueur mon truc de fer
bekkat il fait 5 puisque j'ai vraiment
envie de le laisser arriver jusqu'en
haut 5 tu vois et admettons que j'aie
envie de l'empêcher je fais peut-être
dames série shake en premier je peux
faire dame c5 maintenant tu as déjà tiré
sur la colonne des jordan des six j'ai
changé d'âme c'est fini donc il fait
damas huit ok pas mal joué mais je vais
attendre les six voix il faut enlever si
su contrôler aussi s'il veut sacrifier
le pion et je veux faire des quatre à
cinq et machin voilà j'essaie juste
j'avais d'un prend b2 je suis débile
désolé les mecs temps pour elle de sa
fille c'est juste la partie direct
écouter on va le faire maintenant
ce qu'on peut faire plus propre affaire
d'abus 6 ça évite les trucs avec eux ici
si on y va il veut vraiment éviter aussi
sa faune ce que mange mais à s'échanger
les dames je menace 5 et je menace la
deux voilà comme ça je repars chant
caisse à deux et vous allez voir revenir
je continue à tenir cette case
on va dire que c'est encore plus tu vois
je reviens ici je protège tous quand il
est temps que je suis choix peureux de
folie quoi ça les chalets vraiment
laissé 0 contre eux je vends des fois
c'est un peu too much parfois vaut mieux
calculer c'est plus facile on va refaire
kf 6
alors il fait faut être quatre une fois
un système de long le centre en dire le
chat on va faire g6 allons voir ce qui
nous sort sur g6 l'ombre de quelqu'un
qui a essayé d'avoir le pire lots
possibles il arrive à assen waouh on
peut pas aller plus bas que s'en aller
on va prendre maintenant et on va jouer
des cinq on va proposer d'échanger du
matériel un petit peu et si les changes
tout en d5 l'idée c'est qu'on va réussir
à voir le fou en g7 qui va être très
bien placé vous allez voir ça va les
changer changer changer et valider la
maintenance et qu'on a on va avoir tout
tout est changé au centre et s'il
reprend dessin qu'on va reprendre et on
fait notre fou j'ai sept il sera super
bien placé pour la suite de la partie
vous allez voir ça cela on a réussi à
vider le centre donc c'est une des idées
avec les noirs un généralement de
contrer le centre là on a réussi à
remplir cet objectif si vous voulez
voilà alors là une petite tactique a les
traits au noir comment vous continuez
très haut noir comment continuez vous à
vous de me dire ok qui avait promis 4
reprend des 4 ok alors là risque avait
une deuxième solution
y at il une deuxième solution pour
gagner une pièce d'un petit peu attendre
y at il une deuxième solution les mecs 5
suffirait alors voila moi j'aurais fait
soit quelle épreuve 4 fou prend des
quatre soit qu'est cavalli prend ses
trois premiers ou 5 mais on va faire
quelques points f4 ça paraît quand même
plus simple à calculer ce qui va devoir
prendre et on va faire dame prend des 4
bonsoir le laisse bridges jesse on va
plutôt prendre de la dame toujours avec
la même logique d'échangé les pièces
arrêtons
toujours cette même logique des changes
il fait ça on va faire crisser 6
autour des 1 on va mettre la dame en d4
alors pourquoi pas ce qu'on veut s'en
prendre à cette diagonale un jeu s'en
prendre à cette diagonale et nos
prochains koussa est un coup de foudre
développement peut-être on veut faire h
5 fu g4 histoire de lui fixer les pions
au cas où on fait ou participer au tour
alors faut faire partie du club chaise
comme et puis aller par là alors il a
fallu 5 lui même je pensais bien jouer
on va prendre b2 et on va jouer fou aux
six corps toujours l'idée simple on veut
échanger on veut faire fou prend des
cinq tours prend par exemple les dames
ses trois échecs
on est toujours dans cette logique des
changes alors comment on continue la
comment vous continuez les tontons qui
avait plus dans le temps un francophone
c'est de rester concentré tout en
écoutant les punchline ya pas de punch
lines ce soir où ses trois échecs
parfait
et surtour des deux dames pro d2 a
laissé gagner suivants allaient haugland
jouer pieds ces trois des cinq on va
faire quatre ris prise fait qu'elle ait
17 alors on va tenter ces quatre avec
une petite idée
ok alors très haut blanc je sais pas si
ça marche mais ça peut marcher
ce que les militants qu'on peut tenter
on va tenter foot pro f 7 on va voir
ensemble
il va faire froid prend on va faire
cavaler g5 qui va faire rage et 8
on va faire cavalier ou 6 il va faire
dame 8 warfare qui est français c'est
tifra d'alger s'ils sont traqués et
prend à 8o queyroi 8c faute grave
cavalier 6 gagne la dalle finit pas de
chance sur mille 900 1800 comme on voit
vous pouvez battre des des joueurs à
1800 enjoint de manière un peu un peu
intéressante un peu malines ça peut
fonctionner
car adieu 5 eca et prend des 8 es là
maintenant on a une âme de plus et on va
se développer tout bêtement
développer on va se développer on va se
développer c'est pas bougé comme un
cavalier la dame et non enfin pas de
chance hein on va juste se développer on
va faire cavalier 5 tranquillement sans
va provoquer des échanges toujours cette
même idée s'y prend on reprend va
provoquer des échanges on va ouvrir les
lignes ci fait faux vuitton prendra
aussi g6 et aussi on gagnera un pion
on a plein de solutions mais j'arrive
prendre 17 même si c'est mauvais fou
pour aller à taper ce pion en force et
ouvrir tout la position tours 1-1 et va
devoir faire cavalier fuite on va
essayer ces quatre des cinq on va tout
ouvrir peut-être pas le mieux pour
gagner 1 ou là bas j'ai ouvert le lien
sans faire exprès alors il a joué 5 bat
écouter on va prendre 5
il va devoir faire qui est 17 gagne pas
immédiatement quel dessein était gagnant
n'hésitez pas c'est pas forcé forcé les
prochaines parties prochaine partie
varta qu à l'art corps du christ et 3
écouter ça pas mal marché
cinq cavaliers f3 voir ce qui nous fait
émanant des quatre ça peut ressembler à
une écossaise finalement si on prend
prend 2,4
naret ces suicides touchent mtbf j'avais
surtout eskom tv j'oublie tout parfois
non de l'ouverture du coup aucune idée
mais là on a retourné retomber dans une
écossaise fahva retour dans un genre de
média pas le carillon c6 mon retour dans
l'histoire du d'un genre des décos 16 là
il peut faire ces cinq ans prenant à
faire cavalier f3 on va jouer contre ses
pions la halle et j'ai envie de tenter
au 5 avec l'idée que si prend f3 je
prends un f3 et ya bessette qui reste en
prise et s'il avait pris en 5 j'aurais
pris en des 8es repris y en a eu cinq
n'a du coup il a ça qui reste en prise
après c'est pas si grave
il commence par là même sa tasse est pas
bête ce fameux 7 non j'ai fait refouler
5e chaque l'idée sexy mais on sait 6 je
le prends et que je vais gagner la tour
et six mille cavaliers en 17
je vais quand même prendre ici je vais
vous provoquer ci reprend la dame nature
est fou et 3 et puis après je vais
rapidement faire rock et non prendre un
peu à sa dame peut-être il y aura la
tour emprise aussi donc ce sera pas mal
par la crise et si ça c'est un problème
ce que je vais prendre il va prendre je
vais prendre et je vais aller prendre un
mais donc là du coup il a ça et ça
qu'ils sont attaqués ils en sueur et le
pire c'est qu'il va se faire reprendre
la tour sur échec à l'heure actuelle
c'est fini déjà il va devoir faire d'amd
8 on va échanger les dames et on a une
tour de plus et ça va être très très
simple à gagner à l'échangé on échange
encore on va développer le fou à faire
grand roque et on va être gagnant
bon là il craque complètement bien tous
qui tombe je suis plus que de gagner
et il a finalement abandonné parties
suivantes contrat aidé ou not know donc
le mec ne sait rien alors à continuer ce
cavalier on sait si ç'a bien fonctionné
jusque là et on va jouer avec des cinq
maintenant donc ça existe un truc là
jeudi le 400e prévu la fourchette aura
en retour dans une seconde in av
je rappelle plus trop comment d'où cette
variante ma mémoire me fait défaut
alors j'imagine qu'il prendrait quatre
marches ici parce que lecavalier est
cloué et surtout ces casses je pense
qu'il est pro f 3 échecs très fort alors
pourquoi très fort ce que sur cavaliers
prend et adam prend et sur pions prend
jus pour faire dameuse cinq échecs et
j'ai gagné un pion et en plus d'avoir
gagné ce pion enfin même faire dame c6
d'ailleurs mais on va faire des 25es en
plus arriérées se plonger pourri sa
structure qui fait dames 2 je vais
pouvoir prendre à eux deux et je ne sais
pas si je vais mettre mon fois en 17
pour repartir vers ces six qui peut être
pas mal ou h55 ça paraît plus logique de
base ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
meilleur remettre le pion aussi ça va
permettre de développer de faire un
petit mur devant le fou à développer les
cavaliers on va faire un grand roc comme
ça on va amener une tour en jeu
à développer le fou il va sûrement faire
tour géant métral four angers 6 histoire
de couvrir comme ça on attaque aussi ces
deux au passage on va aller
tranquillement doubler les tours sur la
colonne des en cas de besoin
on remettra une tour alors la fin le fou
sur rfi que j'allais dire mais alors un
cas de figure intéressant on va
commencer par tour 17 ou pas pourquoi on
semble être temps que ça pas mal joué ça
mon affaire tour 17
après s'être jamais fait c4 alors là
très haut noir devrait jouer avec elle
et ses quarante marcheurs s'étaient pas
si simple encore à gagner très haut noir
que va-t-on trouver bon il a abandonné
avez vous prend des 3 il a vu finalement
2 ap qui revient un peu dans le train
qu'il ya 4 sur 6 ha mais il n'a pas le
pas le strict
on est pas mal alors on rejoue contre
vaart à calais refaire caceis et on va
rentrer dans à transposer dans le 4-5-1
risque qui va s'en rendre compte
j'imagine il nous fait une espagnole
qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs voir demain
pendant le match reprend 2d ça me
permettra d'avoir dam des quatre lots
cas échéant ont valu que fouet le
cavalier on ferme des changes de
l'espagnol ce que c'est payant de faire
partie du club de chasse comme tv
français et non pas du tout alors il
phase iii on va jouer h5
l'idée c'est que s'il prend on reprend
et va pousser le cavalier envahissent il
allait faire damage 4 pour les maths et
en h
on va voir si koné ou pas à mettre le
flanc c5 qui est des deux on va faire
becker 7 pouces et 5 g pas si c'était
bon d'air à mediaset c'est très mauvais
ce qui est peut-être qu'il n'ya
peut-être plus on prend prises et
qu'elles progressent alors je suis un
peu n'importe quoi mais ça fonctionne
pour le moment tu m'aimes sûr que je
fais n'importe quoi en fait j'en suis
même sûr mais ça passe ça fonctionne
c'est jamais évident pour des joueurs
débutants est de rester j'allais vous
dire avec ce conflit ce qu'ils ont
toujours de tenter de prendre un moment
mais au moment où ils prennent enfin les
prendre quand j'ai une cavaillon
recettes et qui ont été plantés quoi
parce que j'avais pu le truc de damages
kafala maintenant je l'aide à mach 4
donc il prend aux très mauvais moment et
maintenant il prend 1,5 complètement à
contre temps et je veux faire d'un match
4 et je me demande vraiment comment il
souhaite éviter d'un machin mat
pour moi c'est une vraie question
c'est une vraie question les tontons
je pense un peu similaire mais bon
bosc les f3 mais pas le sur f3 c'est que
c'est un coup illégal et surgit 3 et
d'un machin c'est une vraie question
martin caen / issouf mais jamais facile
à ce niveau là c'est en des changes à
l'exception qu'il y en a eu cinq parce
qu'il faut il faut prendre à bon escient
et c'est vraiment pas évident l'abandon
est une possibilité ici oui je vais
apprendre d'un projet 4 est là bien
évidemment on va lui calé un petit maths
en est reparti comme il ya beaucoup de
joueurs bien classés danse aux alentours
de 2000 il est possible qu'on gagne le
tournant de jointe une heure il est
possible parce qu'ils ont du mal à
garder le strict
ils ont du mal à garder le streak qui se
jouent entre eux nous on a le strict on
tour mon ton monte alors là on va le
prendre physiquement à lui faire des
pions double écoute et s'éprend de
giroud jours avec g3 fou j'ai deux mots
- sanou réglera le problème de la
colonne j'ai quelque part on aura le fou
en fouillant piétons
je porte une structure de type karo kann
alors normal on est plutôt le pion en c6
qui aurait permis de faire un mur face à
mon fou la monf ou heureux mon fou et
heureux mon fou et tout sourire ici
mon fou est tout sourire alors j'aurai
envie de faire ces trois des quatre mais
je vais me faire planter un petit fou
des trois donc on va mettre le pion
peut-être mettre le carillon eux deux on
va toucher un minimum de choses on va
laisser venir peut-être pas une grande
position que j'essaie d'avoir des idées
donc c3 c3 des cats auraient été parfait
mais ça pourrait appeler la partie de
paulsen morphy on va mettre le pion en
des cats écoutez il faut et on va s'en
va on va en profiter on va échanger ses
fous écoutez je suis pas mécontent de
cet échange ça va me permettre de
développer la tour en c1 et d'éviter les
problèmes sur le pion ces deux je suis
pas convaincu que ce qui vient d y vient
d'investir deux coups pour pour échanger
sont bons fous contre mauvais fou donc
même s'il un problème d'espacé suis pas
convaincu je vais m je vais rockets et
après je jouerai avec ses quatre des
cinq ou quelque chose comme ça peut-être
à trois c4 l'histoire de d'éviter tout
problème alors il veut peut-être me
prendre le fou ça j'ai envie de dire
niet
ça m'embête un peu allez on va essayer
d'être maximalisme peut-être un peu trop
alors on n'était pas si bien bien au
final va faire h3 mais je suis pas
convaincu on n'est pas si bien que ça en
a peut-être dj 4 4 quand même bon
s'étend du jus pensé qu'on était mieux
que ça honnêtement versé 3 on va jouer
un peu solides serrés qu'on aimerait
bien faire grand roque on regrette
finalement dans la tour en c1
on regrette un peu mais bon c'est ça va
quand même comme dirait mur tu as
c'est ça va quand même que nous visons
dans le tchat
le 5 vraiment bt possiblement et mais
bon je peux aussi avoir envie de faire
du danemak atteint un jour ils sont rois
et pas forcément si bien que ça avec du
d4 d5 qui arriverait rapidement mais
c'est vrai que tu pas je suis pas fou
fou fou
j'ai joué un peu original et je suis pas
fou
bon bah on va s'en prendre un peu à son
fou il va reculer on va peut-être mettre
le cavaliere f4 c'est un peu développé
nos pièces parce que c'est pas folichon
folichon donc et à 5 c'est un peu
étrange comme beaucoup il faut il faut
reconnaître qu'on attendait
[Musique]
écoutez je vais prononcer je vais
prendre ni si on en a un petit peu et
changer si on peut échanger les dames
rester avec la bonne structure de pions
enfin genre s'y fait dame prend et on va
prendre ici et on warocqué et on n'est
toujours pas si bien on se fait dominer
on se fait dominer on est toujours assez
mal
bon c'est une partie raté ça arrive on
va faire tour ces deux écouter on va
devoir bloquer colmater comme ça la
deuxième c'est moche mais on va y
arriver
ok on va écouter colmater la deuxième
quand je lui disais qu on colmate
elle va monter le roi ok on met une cour
en d1
on va commencer à se placer un peu avec
nos pièces on va coller une tour en d2
et maintenant tout d'un coup on a un peu
de contre eux je ça c'est sympa parce
qu'il va devoir jouer peut-être cécile
source l'espace on va faire tour des
huit fois à ses sept tours f8 peut-être
on peut commencer à passer
ok
je vais mettre ma tour en d5 séparément
sert à quelque chose
mais banque et ils échangent
j'ai envie de repartir par là je me
disais qu'il sait qu'à tours ici ouais
mais je suis pas si bien a minima
il ya clairement mieux joué que moi j'ai
trois c'était un peu trop peureux un peu
trop original c'était un peu trop
original
j'ai été un peu trop original alors à
faire b3 et on va venir par là même
gagner autant mais il aura vraiment bien
joué mende ex patron d'eon va revenir un
petit coup de fouet aux échecs il
s'approche avec sont rares et ça peut
être dangereux trop s'approcher avec le
roi ça peut être dangereux d'ailleurs là
il vient de se faire clouer et
finalement même prendre de la tour a été
un peu trop optimiste mais il avait plus
assez de temps aux 6 1 il faut quatre
échecs raté peut-être même matech tours
4 donc un ami en sueur on a gagné mais
c'était pas c'était pas propre propre
s'est bien défendu on n'a jamais été
trop en danger
il a fini par craquer allez on va faire
4 un petit peu et un gambit roi aller
contre frost 10
contre frost lice ceux d'omar en france
tunisie alors qu'à rallier là on va
faire cavalier f3 on va faire car il y
est roi frost e ten oui bon enfin
prononce à la française pourquoi pas
ok on va prendre ici et prendre ici
alors ici est ce que dans le cas de
gagner une pièce envie de vous dire non
ses environs se passe pas super bien on
va faire ses 4 quelle idée sur ce point
f3 psion francs des cinq fours en d1
puis on prend ces 6es du coup il reste
avec sa emprise or ce n'était pas
brillant ce qu'en dit roy mais il reste
avec sa emprise et sa emprise mais bon
j'ai mal joué et mérité mieux donc
maintenant on va prendre 17
on va faire fouiller 5e j'ai mal calculé
j'aurais dû faire foule est 5e le pion
prend bessette bas j'aurais fait fou
mais ça y est peut-être b 6 mai france
et sa toile foulée 5t prix fort sur
fouquet 5 maintenant il ya roi des 8
je suis pas concentré à fond pour être
le fond à 6 du coût
ok je joue comme ça écoutez je vais
faire rock ça me permettent de reprendre
de la tour éventuellement mais j'ai
quand même très bien parce que bon piont
v7 est quand même fort à faire payer ces
trois comme ça mon cavalier il n'empêche
un peu de revenir et maintenant c'est
peut-être le moment de prendre une fois
ici et de faire cavalier b5 ce qui va
permettre d'attaquer de vie et nuit truc
c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle on a 1 2 3 4
5 6 contre 5 donc on a déjà un pion de
plus et là on arrive à deux pions de
plus et surtout on a trois pions passé
lié pas trois pions passé entre
guillemets nom d'heuliez en baisse est
très fort et maintenant menace de
revenir vers la case c6 donc ce qu'on va
faire maintenant et donc de de gagner
encore une qualité quoi ce qu'on va
faire d'ailleurs et on évite cavalli b4
au passage
sachant qu'on a six tours f5 peut-être
un double attaque
peut-être le gagnant ce tournoi ça va
défendre des autres affaires tour c'est
un comme ça on veut faire qui reprend
des huit tours prend et tour c'est 8
si on regarde les tours sous pression du
coup maintenant il a bougé une tour ça
nous fait gagner un temps en fait je
vais à faire tomber vite il aura fait
deux coups de tours on va lui mettre une
tour ans et 8 et frost qui va être en
sûrs mais tombait fort insérant notre
chance et arthur arthur tuerie à 2 ap ya
du monde il ya du monde dans son bras
c'est notre chance parce qu'ils vont
être un sur la pub ou fait le pion
quitte à perdre la touraine mais bon il
aurait perdu la tourte ont même vous
serez pas été évident alors on a un
adversaire qui va vite nous cacher la
dame
aller à jouer
cette variante qui arrange a demandé
huit mois j'aurai groc 5 et on va
préparer g4 f4 allez c'est parti met une
tour en f1 et on va envoyer à f 5
je n'étais pas obligé de mettre la tour
en f1 mais bon déjà sur le coup d'avant
des huit n'ont pas très bien placé ce
que le roi d'ailleurs ils à leur nom des
six le roi est un peu en sueur et
maintenant on va prendre des 5
et voilà le travail
la scandinave en sueur a hélas on va lui
placer le petit fauve et 4 qui fait
plaise et qui nous fait gagner c'est sûr
faire une ce qu'en dit contre moi
c'était un petit peu suicidaire et se
permet de gagner vite pour pour faire
les carnets dans l'objectif de gagner
ce qu'en dit contre moi fallait avoir
une belle paire de couilles il a eu
cette paire de couilles mais elle lui a
pas été très utile elle n'était pas en
acier inoxydable
malheureusement pour lui toujours
important de l'avoir en acier inoxydable
et ouais moi quand je recule madame
valeant c'est certain du coup par
rapport à ce qu'il a fait je gagne un
temps c'est inoxydable n'était pas là
alec et 17
j'en sors toujours des punchline rôle ce
n'est pas une bonne chose non c'était
une punchline vrai dire qu'avec une
paire du coup n'est pas en acier
inoxydable ouais c'est une semi
punchline ont bon je suis pas assez
gentil à la ff iv et alors on va jouer
gros rock c'était une punchline est
voilà une punchy net
stephen chine est
alors on va les envoyer g5 c'est un peu
classique dans l'est les ouvertures
genre les françaises truc comme ça à ce
mec tu veux t'en prendre à eux cinq en
force et tu le dvi mais ça c'est pas mal
parce que du coup on s'en prend à f4
directement on s'en prend à eux cinq et
on ouvre la colonne j'ai pour lui
attaqué le roi donc là on a vu dans la
partie précédente une scandinaves qui
était mal de malmener une scandinaves en
sueur et là on voit une scandinave bien
mener donc une scandinave à fond et on
va faire un petit coup de tours g8 en
retour j'ai vite c'est pas mal ce que tu
mets ta tour en face et tu prépares sur
tours d infliger quatre comme ça tu tu
développes et labine cavaliers prend 1,5
est ce que c'est si bon j'en suis pas si
sûr mais ça m'a permis de faire bim ares
et green bean mon avis a pas être
mauvais mais bon je pas si sûr de moi
que ça il fait dams et 3 mai sur dame c3
je comptais faire dame des six échecs
ras-le-bol ne va pas marcher bon j'ai
une idée de beau jeu je pense fouet
trois seul coup à j'avais maintenant à
temps j'ai plusieurs solutions enr
solution numéro un tour pranger de roy
projet de fou preuve quatre solutions
numéro deux cavaliers f3 échec
normal on va faire le tour pranger de
fou prend 2,4
ce que c'est si bon je suis pas sûr non
plus et man ouest qui met son roi
réalité ce que sylvain f1 je fais damas
6,6 van asch 3 son rang il paraît
complètement bois s'y vend ici chez
kelly et carey missy man ray fin je fais
dan des cinq mêmes
du coup je recolle un échec je protège
mon cavalier et surtout rodez va se
faire claquer un petit fou b4
enfermement de dames auquel on qui
repart par là bas mais il s'est quand
même collé fou b4 et yaya toure g8 qui
arrive donc là on voit un max h en sueur
la sueur de max hachlaf l'aca à grosse
boucle a hélas issou qu à fin il n'en
peut plus on voit la différence entre la
bonne airways candidats place royale
précédente qu'un 14 coup les blancs les
les noirs ont abandonné et la parie sur
une bonne scandinaves et aux 22e coup on
voit les blancs sueur l'aï su là il va
être obligé de retour écologie va se
prendre cavaillé prendre trois échecs à
la découverte est fou prend ces trois
cas voilà il n'y a plus rien pour
lorgner sur une scandinave de haut vol
là on est sur une course très nette de
compétition là les mecs
regardez c'est la scandinave de
compétition ça d'ailleurs il ya eu un
bon nom donc ouais c'est la différence
entre la bonne et la mauvaise candidate
c'est un vrai scandale
tu la joues tu perds en 18 coups la
bonne ce voyage tu la joues en 22 coups
de mike et en sueur elles ont fini par
étals on va lui faire un petit os 4 il
nous fait aussi son va lui faire ses
cartons à ce que connaît et anne les
talents sur les tannants sueur ou pas
nike se sont sûres
areski italien en sueur ou pas est ce
que ethan et en sueur
je pense que thein sein est en sueur il
se dit je joue ma petite française on
lui demande que je connais pas c'est ça
les amis on sent de la théorie fin on
sort ça existe c'est cap et tu vois on
veut contrer avec et 2000 efforts et a
été fort et avec un bon joueur au
deuxième coup sort de la théorie qui
voyez là j'ai appris la française sur
alger tu vois il joue au foot échec il
est partout elle rêve fou prend 1,6 et
là on censure n'est peut-être pas moins
bien mais bien sûr ni su alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire de marans
il sut sangsues et quand même issue sans
suer c'est pas mal ce qui fait il se mit
su
ouais c'est bien ce qu'il fait est un
bravo il s'en sort il sut patron va
faire à 3 mai à faire peut-être
cavaliers cher froid ici et sur cavani
f4 on sera dans la merde
préval depuis le temps qui suit les
stream c'est quasiment un copain même si
j'ai jamais vue de ma vie je pensais
qu'il ait fait retirer les f4 et prend
aussi ce qu'est france est un
c'est un peu soupçonnant comme coup
parce que du coup il fait changer les
dames et il se prend kébé 5 à la fin
vous allez voir le truc et b5 la très
franchement ce cavalier à leucate est
très fort mais l'accueil des 5 ça lui
pose un vrai problème est obligé de
faire ça et du coup il se moquait france
et cette prise est en france à sept
pions 2 - tours 7e et anne qui sut issue
totalement healy issue il est issu ça
peut être une nouvelle ère un nouveau
tour de vis ou du coup ils essayent de
venir colmatée mais à deuxième tour qui
arrive il en prendre partout la haye
l'empreinte partout c'est moche
ces vaches parce qu'ils auraient fait
qu'il y ait des trois kf4 échec était
pas mal mais mais là il en prendre
partout là c'est horrible à ces
horribles assez terrible pour ethan
assez terrible en plus il est deuxième
c'est lui qui pouvait nous rattraper il
avait le strict il avait tout pour lui
on est mais il s'est pris une cartouche
il s'est pris une cartouche alors qu'ils
étaient pas mal bon j'ai relancé une
partir que le stream devrait finir
est-ce que j'ai le temps d'enlever oui
boom naturel oui naturel oui elle avait
tenu bon au début et il aurait pu
naturel oui il aurait pu faire cavaler
f4 sur quoi j'ai calculé roi f3
cavaliers pro sys d'un prend 17
cavaliers des quatre échecs roi g3 est
d'amuser 5
et là c'est carrément mal voire perdant
donc je pouvais pas faire ça
donc du coup ce qu'est je vais jouer dan
droit ici sur quoi tu es sûr qu'ils
éprouvent aussi ce week end à me prends
ici mais il aurait pu faire dame prend
et sur dame premier set est sûrement un
truc
une dame ces quatre étrangers deux donc
j'aurais dû échanger des dames il
reprend du cavalier cavaliers f3 et une
mauvaise structure de pions il est bien
mais bien résisté mais il a fini par par
crack adéquat donc sympa ce tournoi je
pense qu'on va le gagner quand même
parce que du coup et a n'a pas le strict
ça m'étonnerait quand 58 qui nous met 22
points ça dépend des appariements tout
cas fait une belle partie et ça lui
ferait un truc à étudier donc merci à
vous tous d'avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain pour le match carlson caruana en
espérant que je puisse être live parce
que j'ai toujours pas jésus milliards à
dernier moment est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai fait ce que j'ai reçu quelque chose
et ce que j'ai reçu une un mail
ce que j'ai reçu quelque chose
tu en train de checker avec le téléphone
j'ai aucune nouvelle j'ai aucune
nouvelle il est 21h30
ça commence dans dix huit heures et je
n'ai aucune nouvelle d'eux comme envoyer
le stream je n'ai pas de design je n'ai
pas d'échiquier je n'ai rien branler
espérons que en espérant que ça marche
j'y peux rien les mecs fut vraiment
désolé j'espère vraiment que ça marchera
bon sur ce les mecs merci d'avoir suivi
et on se tient au courant
on se tient au courant ben tu
m'inquiètes un peu pour la ronde 1 mais
vous inquiétez pas en deux rondes trois
ce sera avant merci à tous les temps